imagine suffering a plane crash above
the ocean with only you and one other
passenger surviving both of you get
washed up on a deserted island with
nothing but sandbanks and palm trees
once you wake up on the shore and look
around you notice the other survivor's
footprints looks like he woke up before
you
as you explore the island you find him
sitting on a huge pile of coconuts turns
out while you were unconscious he went
around and collected every single
coconut on the island for himself
coconuts that you would also need if you
don't want to starve of course you could
go and try your luck catching some fish
along the shore but according to
statistics 9 out of 10 startup fishermen
end up dying of hunger in the end the
coconuts are your only realistic chance
at survival so you ask him
can you give me some coconuts please and
he says sure i can give you some
coconuts
if you suck my dick
[Laughter]
you are faced with a conundrum do you
suck the coconut man's dick let's keep
this question in mind for later
my political views and consequently my
urban planning and transit views are all
informed by one overarching value i want
as many people as possible to live the
best lives they can with the largest
possible degree of freedom in practice
this means that every adult person
should be free to do whatever they want
as long as they don't harm others
physically mentally or financially and
just to clarify i am pro-choice i don't
think the fetus is a full-fledged person
so the mother's interest should take
priority so as a freedom-loving person
it should be self-explanatory that i
support ideologies such as free market
capitalism or even anarcho-capitalism
right so what do these two ideologies
entail in a free market capitalist
system the economy operates with very
little to no government intervention now
keep in mind that we're only talking
about the markets here in every other
aspect of life the government can be
very much repressive for example even
totalitarian dictatorships can be free
market or at least lean towards it in
contrast anarcho-capitalism is a system
without a government or at least a
centralized institution able to affect
coercion on you everything is left up to
the free market and the people's
self-organization and i'm here to make
the case that within a short amount of
time both systems would devolve into a
horrifying authoritarian dictatorship
but how come these two ideologies would
bring about the exact things they are
designed to alleviate namely oppression
and coercion let's take a look first at
free market capitalism and my question
to you is is your workplace democratic
and by that i mean do you as an employee
have a say in how your workplace is run
well not really right maybe in like a
very small business but even then you
don't have any say in the meaningful
decisions like if there's say five of
you working at a small restaurant as
waiters you can ask the owner to for
example rearrange the tables a bit
because right now the layout is super
inconvenient to navigate with a bunch of
plates in your hand but the outcome of
that request is still completely
determined by the goodwill of the owner
they can say yeah sure how do you want
to organize the tables or nope sorry the
layout is good the way it is and for me
this is like a little chiefdom if you
will it's a small community you get the
chief running things and everyone can
just go and petition the chief
personally if they want to but see the
outcome of the request is still
determined completely by the chieftain
even if all five of you go to them and
say so here's a petition all five of us
have voted to rearrange the table layout
the chieftain can still go yeah i
disagree with that so too bad we end up
with a system where the will of the
people will be taken into account if and
only if a the leader is a nice person b
the leader is afraid that some of the
subordinates might quit and so they
would need to spend more time and money
on additional recruitment or c the
leader believes that the new table
arrangement would lead to more efficient
work and so the business would make more
money so here whether the will of the
people will be taken into account
depends on a personal kindness b fear of
losing money and c the promise of more
money so as you can see this is not
exactly the perfect recipe for freedom
so what happens in a bigger business
with more employees big business takes
the concept of chiefdom and upgrades it
to a totalitarian dictatorship as bob
black wrote in his essay the abolition
of work work makes a mockery of freedom
the official line is that we all have
rights and live in a democracy other
unfortunates who aren't free like we are
are forced to live in police states
these victims obey orders or else no
matter how arbitrary the authorities
keep them on the regular surveillance
state bureaucrats control even the
smaller details of everyday life the
officials who push them around are
answerable only to higher-ups public or
private either way descent and
disobedience are punished informers
report regularly to the authorities all
this is supposed to be a very bad thing
and so it is although it is nothing but
a description of the modern workplace a
great example of this is when major
corporations try to prevent workers
unions from forming also known as union
busting a practice that is illegal mind
you but they still do it anyway for
example have you heard about this
company called tesla and its owner elon
musk and to quote from a vox article
titled elon musk broke u.s labor laws on
twitter tesla tried many different
tactics to stop workers from forming a
labor union tesla workers distributing
pro-union leaflets in the parking lot in
their time off were harassed by three
security guards a supervisor later
warned them that they could be fired for
distributing those leaflets summoning
the organizers into his office elon musk
illegally tried to dissuade the workers
from forming a workers union and as
leaked emails have shown the hr
department tried to put the organizers
into management so they won't be able to
organize a union on the factory floor
and then once again illegally tesla
banned employees from wearing pro union
t-shirts and buttons and also illegally
tesla fired one of the organizers
co-workers who criticized tesla
employees who spoke out against the
union-backed bill and then repeat after
me illegally elon musk tweeted out the
following nothing stopping tesla team at
our car plan from voting union could
those who tomorrow if they wanted but
why pay union dues and give up your
stock options for nothing our safety
record is two times better than when the
plant was uew and everybody already gets
health care
okay in other words nothing stopping the
peasantry in our kingdom from enacting
democracy could do tomorrow if they
wanted but why get your head chopped off
for nothing law and order is two times
better than when kingdom was under louis
xiii and we already have the code louis
alright so at this point what real
choice does the employee have proponents
of free market capitalism usually bring
up the fact that the workers can just
switch workplaces or you know just move
to another city this is the freedom that
workers have but is it though you know
changing your workplace is not an easy
thing to do i know because i've done it
before it's long time consuming
financially difficult chances are you'll
be without a salary for at least a month
not to mention how stressful it can be
not to mention the older you get the
more difficult it will become to get
hired i know people personally who try
to change their jobs in their mid 40s
despite them being super qualified with
ton of experience in a booming job
market it was still super difficult also
what if there's nothing for you to do in
your area what if you live in some small
town in some flyover state with like one
walmart and two other workplaces and you
want to quit your current job because
your employer wants to cut your salary
to five dollars per hour and increase
your work hours to 16 hours per day
because under free market capitalism
they are allowed to do that trust me
there's a lot of things corporations
would do under a free market system like
violating your privacy online or offline
or selling off your sensitive
information for money speaking of which
today's video is sponsored by atlas vpn
atlas vpn is a tool that encrypts your
data and hides your virtual location
thus protecting your privacy and
allowing you to bypass region logs with
atlas vpn you're going to have access to
all that content on streaming platforms
such as netflix that has been previously
logged away from you all you need to do
is open the application pick out a
server from the list and you're done
atlas vpn also comes bundled with a
nifty breach scanner feature open the
menu inside the app enter an email
address and the app will show you
whether there have been any leaks
associated with that email address and
as an ended line of defense the app also
allows you to block unwanted trackers
from websites just flip the switch and
you're done atlas vpn runs both on
desktop and on mobile and of course it's
compatible with all major operating
systems right now atlas vpn is running a
huge discount on their 3-year plan this
means you can subscribe to their
services for just one dollar and 39
cents per month this and the 30 day
money back guarantee of course this
offer won't last forever so do check it
out link in the description protect your
privacy and don't let region block stop
you take advantage of this insane
discount today thank you for checking
out atlas vpn ads like this helps
support the show you will find my
affiliate link down in the description
[Music]
according to proponents of free market
capitalism if you are out of options
your main recourse is just to move to a
different city now of course this can be
a fine solution but we cannot ignore
just how destructive it can also be
moving to a new area can be hugely
stressful i know because i've done it
before not to mention if you move from
some flyover state to say a coastal
state you'll be leaving behind friends
family acquaintances i.e you will lose
your social safety net and you will lose
your community and this is made all the
worse if you have say school-age
children you have to take them with you
that means leaving behind their school
their friends hell even maybe their
boyfriends or girlfriends the teachers
they knew the neighborhood they grew up
in maybe even the grandparents or other
relatives who also lived there now i'm
no child psychology expert but i don't
think for some reason that that's
particularly conducive for the child's
development the only group of people who
would not be affected by the negative
consequences of moving that much would
be young adults between the ages of 18
and 25 who are hyper online don't leave
the house that often and have very few
to know real life friends and so let us
now talk about anarcho-capitalism and
what its proponents want to bring about
and so as we discussed before free
market capitalism doesn't want
government influence in the market
however the state can be very much
present in other aspects of life for
example they can still provide public
services and infrastructure next to the
private ones anarcho-capitalism however
in its primal form is a stateless
society there is no government
everything depends on people's
self-organization and the free market
all the functions that were performed by
the government previously are now
completely privatized meaning you could
live on your private property and freely
contract with anyone else without any
coercion as long as they basically just
don't mess with other people also called
the non-aggression principle this means
that technically you would be able to
live a life of absolute freedom well
until the amazon gestapo shows up and
tells you that you are now under the
rule of holy jeff bezos the first and
anyone opposing him will be decapitated
in an amazon warehouse and their body
parts will be sent to their family
members as a warning in boxes with
same-day amazon prime delivery but hey
if you don't agree with this you'll be
perfectly free to start reciting the
non-aggression principle until the
firing squad officer tells you to shut
the [ __ ] up and keep digging so i
believe by now all of us can start
seeing the problem the fatal flaw at the
core of free market capitalism and
consequently anarcho-capitalism both
ideologies seek to increase the power
and influence of institutions that are
autocratic in nature traditional
corporations are set up like
dictatorships the owner has absolute
control and the subordinates can only
hold the owner accountable through a
government which in the first world is a
parallel democratic more powerful power
structure and so it can hold the
corporate autocratic power structures
accountable if you get rid of it then
the only game remaining in town will be
the autocratic power structures meaning
they'll be the ones with ultimate
control in free market capitalism
they'll control the economy and who
knows maybe more things by proxy and in
anarcho-capitalism they'll control
everything and guess what coercion
happens to be the central part of any
autocracy so if your goal is the lack of
coercion then free market capitalism or
anarcho-capitalism should be the last
things you would want and i'm confident
in making this statement because
coercion already exists in the current
system and it's not coming from the
government if your only choice is to
work some shitty job or be homeless as
is the case for millions of people then
i would say you are not really free i
mean hey you do have the option to quit
and be homeless but is that really the
type of freedom you would want and so
let us now circle back to the original
question do you suck the coconut man's
dick hey you're free not to
with dying of hunger as the consequence
and that's i believe to be coercion if
you want a system with the maximum
possible amount of freedom and the
minimum possible amount of coercion then
if i were you i would not base it on the
current form of capitalism a system that
is autocratic in nature but i do think
there is a solution actually namely
workplace democracy give workers more
control over their own workplace curtail
the absolute power of business owners
let workers democratically decide how
profits will be allocated so i would
personally just give a tax break to any
worker co-op firms and see if they work
out if they do hell yeah let's have more
if not well i guess we'll just have to
figure out something else but there are
pretty successful examples already so
i've known that they would work out
actually now upon hearing this you might
ask okay adam but if co-ops are so good
and you know better than traditional
firms how can we still have traditional
firms how come we haven't transitioned
into worker co-ops well consider the
following just because a system is
better it doesn't mean that we will
automatically transition to it the
prerequisites of capitalism existed
centuries before capitalism itself and i
do believe that the next step after late
stage capitalism the system we have
currently would be co-op-based
capitalism in any case we need something
new and we need it now and free market
capitalism or anarcho-capitalism are
just not going to cut it they're just
more the same and i believe we've all
had enough of that already you know
coconuts and all thank you for watching
please like and subscribe if you haven't
already and do check out my patreon link
in the description and i'll be seeing
you next time
you